starwars the last Jedi has been very
divisive with fans and has garnered both
immense praise and serious criticism at
the same time while some see it as the
best of the series others rather seen it
political agendas being played out in
story form I've described my own
experience of watching the movie as
being similar to eating a soup you
really like but then finding a hair in
every spoonful to tell you the truth I
hadn't intended to make a video on the
last Jedi but it's really the barrage of
messages
I caught asking for it which prompted me
to do this I enjoyed certain aspects of
the movie very much the visuals were
astounding and some of the threads were
very interesting but I found the solicit
of social and political messages to
constantly get in the way on being
convinced that it had a coherent
symbolic world hopefully I can give some
insight into what brought about such an
experience
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
I've expressed my difficulty with Star
Wars symbolism before you'll find a link
in the description to where I discussed
this to me there is a basic confusion
with how the imagery of the force is set
up and this problem perpetuates itself
in the latest movie the force has a
light and a dark side light is related
to discipline self mastery self
knowledge for all intents and purposes
it's the good side of the force the dark
side of the force is related to anger to
passions to revenge and resentment you
know of a letting go of your discipline
self mastery and control in general it's
seen as the bad side of the force
now maybe except for you know that
simple morality all of this makes sense
in terms of symbolism but the problem in
the Star Wars movies is that the dark
side in its political sphere ends up
being related to excessive order
excessive purity a huge Galactic Empire
with pristine clean white stormtroopers
triangle-shaped ships you know a giant
planet sized base with a laser beam for
shooting planets it screams too much
order too much light and so there are
these strange contradictory scenes in
the movies where Luke for example is
told to give in to his rage to kill his
father fulfill your destiny and take
your father's place at my side
but then this should somehow bring about
him becoming a leader in the most
sophisticated techno bureaucratic
military state you know ever imagined
it's difficult to see how that works out
the light side of the force ends up
being related to some dusty rebellion
clandestine smugglers furtive
infiltration operations stealing plans
and all kinds of chaotic guerrilla
tactics of well rebels trying to
overthrow order and within that there's
a weird aristocracy being set up
Princess Leia and Luke discovering that
they are in fact part of a very special
lineage where the force is strong and by
virtue of their family and they are
intense training they could become Jedi
Masters and so here is a form of
aristocracy defending rebellion and
democratic ideals of course part of the
problem is seeing light as only good and
dark as only bad because you know there
is such a thing as an excess of light
there is such a thing as an excess of
order just as there is sometimes a need
to be crafty like a serpent to use
furtive and dark means to tackle
corrupted authorities characters like
Batman's or vigilantes in general could
be seen as an example of a character
that works outside the system outside
the order uses the dark side of the
force we could say in order to break up
corruption in the end the only way I
could make sense of this of the whole
Star Wars symbolism is to think that
episodes four through six what we're
dealing with is the end of a world you
know where the world is upside down
possibly an image of our own world
somewhat like in the story of Elijah
where the prophets of God hide in a cave
while a strange harlot you know has
married the king bringing about an
inverted tyranny of foreign gods we
could see it in the manner that we can
it
experience a tyranny of our own passions
our own desires how we can become a
slave to those desires but this is
always to our own destruction so then in
Star Wars this inevitable untenable
upside-down world let's say this extreme
world would inevitably lead to a
cataclysm a double inversion an
inversion of the inversion as I've
discussed in other videos that is Anakin
the chosen one you're the chosen one
having gone to the dark side bring about
this upside-down world where the dark
side can enact strangely this excessive
order now would return to the light side
and establish a new balance in the force
right that was the only way I could make
sense of this now I think that this
symbolic problem that I've described
this inversion rather than being solved
in the latest movie it's actually what
is being played out and maybe even
radicalized in the last Jedi so how does
this appear for example there's been
much talk about how the character of Rey
is a Mary Sue but the question is why
she's a Mary Sue what does it mean you
see a Mary Sue is the name given to a
type of character which began popping up
with the development of fanfiction this
type of character is a young prodigy who
has unprecedented and inexplicable
skills and all of the domains of the
movie and can be seen as besting the
traditional characters at whatever you
know makes them unique so and they can
do this without any training or
explicable reason as to why the
character is so amazing so the reason
why rey is considered a Mary Sue is that
although she comes out of nowhere she's
this amazing fighter the best pilot she
fixes Hans ship better you know then he
can
what'd you do I bypassed the compressor
huh she beats kylo Ren the first time
she fights with a lightsaber she beats
Luke even in the latest movie and she
does this without any explanation
whatsoever as to how it is she can do
all these things
I mean herself having grown up as a
scavenger on some forsaken desert world
in the original trilogy Luke had to
train and he was even berated for not
finishing his training the the Jedi had
to join the Jedi Order and they they
lived a life of austere monastic
discipline in order to master the force
but Rey she can do it all without any
training whatsoever
and when she does train with Luke in the
last Jedi we discover rapidly that she's
already bested Luke in all the ways that
matter even before he really attempts to
trainer the fact that this type of
character this MarySue character was
born in fan fiction is not surprising
and maybe this is a good lesson in
symbolism fan fiction is itself a form
of inversion of order where it is those
who are on the receiving end of a story
the public the fans who now turn around
and attempt to produce content within
the story frame that they became fans of
in that sense fanfiction is a form of
revolution of course it is a benign
revolution but pondering this can help
us understand what a revolution is what
a rise of chaos can look like how it can
often appear as an unreasonable
wish-fulfillment like a group of
peasants who imagined that they could
take over their Lords castle like a
group of factory workers who imagined
they could take over a factory even
though they have no idea
to run it though in their imagination of
course they would do it better than the
current leaders ever could we all have
these type of self-indulgent fantasies
we find ourselves playing over and over
in our mind imagining ourselves as you
know the new lead singer of a band we
like fantasizing about winning the
basketball championship with or with or
against our favorite player these types
of fantasies can run over and over in
our mind with only the very slight
modification and I think that type of
self-indulgence is what the force
awakens was trying to be a kind of
fetishism on a new hope that movie that
had drawn a whole generation into a
sometimes obsessive relationship with
Star Wars a revolutionary mindset is
based on the notion that there is no
hierarchy of competence that there are
never reasons never reasons which accord
with how the world exists you know for
why the world is ordered in a certain
way and though I'm talking about social
revolution there is another more
intimate angle to this we recently heard
much on let's call it the Liberty side
of the current political battle about
social justice and the snowflake
Generation this social presupposition
that each person is special and has
unlimited potential each person can be
whatever they want and if they can't
it's not about them but rather because
of a system that's unfair or rigged
against them or how their parents or
some authority figure crushed their
natural creativity it's all obi wan's
fault and so in this vision a person
does not need to be trained does not
need discipline does not even need a
character arc at all but
needs to be let loose so to unleash the
the special person they are on the world
and for people who have accepted this
worldview there is no problem with a
character like Rey she fits perfectly in
their frame of the world Rey is the
millennial hero par excellence no doubt
about it now Star Wars was from from the
beginning was of course post-world War
two
propaganda obviously and that's fine to
a certain extent the Empire you know was
a techno bureaucratic military state
which makes everything regular and
uniformed
using overt Nazi symbolism they were the
axis and the rebellion was the last
breath of a republic which functioned as
a collegial governing body amongst a
large diversity of peoples and cultures
basically the Allies but mostly really
the United States and it's ideal of
democracy my allegiance is to the
Republic to democracy in all of this
using Farwest cowboy symbolism of the
individual hero against the tyrannical
system basically Martin Luther standing
up to the corrupt Catholic Church so the
ideal was freedom and in general I would
say it was pretty effective but as I
said earlier because of the big mashup
because of this strange idea of the the
Jedi Order and the light side of the
force being on the side of rebellion and
the Republic finding this Republic being
de vente fended by a highly hierarchical
religious order of samurai like monks
maybe the propaganda wasn't so
transparent as it has become in the
latest movie now one of the things that
makes the propaganda in the latest Star
Wars movie more obvious is the change of
ideals the ideal is no longer freedom it
seems but safety from oppression
that's not the same thing it's no longer
about heroism in the face of tyranny as
it is about a new ideal of social
justice so if so if in the first trilogy
it was by heroism especially individual
heroism that freedom could be found in
the latest movie heroism but not really
just heroism but specifically masculine
heroism is criticized relentlessly when
PO is degraded by Leia the movie itself
makes the link to masculinity clear
because Leia tells Poe to get his head
out of his cockpit there are countless
examples but we see this strange attack
on masculine heroine heroism at its
strongest point when Rose prevents Finn
from destroying the Canon by sacrificing
himself Finn who has constantly shown
himself to be a coward from the force
awakens constantly there to take the
backseat to his female counterpart in
every possible situation now finally
having the courage to sacrifice himself
in an act that would have been the mere
reflection of what Admiral hold oh did
just before and for which you know she's
meant to be admired but here ro stops
him calls him a dummy and gives him one
more nagging lesson that it is not by
fighting those we hate but by saving
those we love that we will beat them
which is very disturbing because
obviously he was going to destroy the
Canon to protect those he loves so the
change of ideal seems to be putting the
odd aspects of Star Wars in place the
notion that the Jedi Order was a
positive good was never congruent with
the ideals of rebellion and so now the
only order is the first order and that
order is shown and even
stranger caricature ol guys is that it
that it than it ever was led by an
irrational tantrum prone kylo Ren and
the Weasley unconvincing general Hux and
the fact that all these incompetent
leaders are shown constantly squabbling
and publicly berating each other shows
us again this belief that order is
accidental it has nothing to do with
competence only with raw power I mean we
wonder why any soldier would ever follow
orders given by someone like general Hux
so in order for things to fit properly
the Jedi Order has to be eliminated it's
time for the Jedi and the notion of a
sacred tradition passed down a human
chain connecting us to a immemorial past
is portrayed as somewhat useless and
silly Yoda burns down the sacred place
and just you know just to teach Luke one
more lesson in all notions of
aristocracy lineage in terms of family
or religious tradition competence as
acquired through effort and discipline
you know and by connecting oneself to a
lineage of masters all of this is
eliminated in order to make way for the
force as accidental and somewhat
democratic a truly we could call it
new-age version of the force and a and a
truly social justice version of politics
or the purpose is more to preserve the
safety of the oppressed rather than to
be freed from tyranny and it's important
to understand this freed from tyranny
but not only not mostly from the outside
but in the earlier movies being freed
from tyranny was being freed from the
tyranny of our own passions
never I'll never turn to the dark side
that's what was positive about about the
first Star Wars movies and also what is
gone here we have to remember that when
Luke went down into the cave during his
training he encountered Vader and kills
him only to discover that in fighting
out of anger
he's encountering his own dark side
which is his true enemy
but now when Rey goes down into the cave
it's all good
she has no conflict if she's already
completely integrated and and if Luke is
seen to discover his nemesis as himself
Rey is made to discover that she is her
own origin when she asks to see her
parents she sees herself and when she
discovers her causality she's in line
with herself
that is the very revolution the very
break with order that the whole movie
exhibits and that order is arbitrary and
must be inverted and inverted is truly
the word to use here because alongside
the whole discourse about freeing
animals destruction of lineage and
tradition this new democratic force
there is a whole thread in the movie
represented by Poe and his relationship
with Leia first you know and second to
the purple haired Admiral holdout that
is fall in line buddy don't question
orders
know your place check your priveledge in
our resistance to the first order so in
the end although like I said at the
beginning I really wanted to enjoy the
movie it was a struggle to and if I
could I would order a bit less hair in
my Star Wars suit for next time
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved
I'd love to read your insights and
questions in the comments section you
can also share this video on social
media to your friends and as you can
please consider supporting us
financially through patreon or PayPal
you'll find those links in the
description below